bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du home pod d'apple le nouveau produit
la nouvelle enceinte connectés qui va
arriver bientôt chez vous et vous allez
voir que derrière cette enceinte
il ya beaucoup plus de choses qu'on ne
pourrait croire et s'en va le voir
maintenant
[Musique]
le ipod d'apple arrive enfin ça fait un
petit moment que l'êta annoncé on
l'attend depuis de nombreux mois
et enfin ils commencent à pointer le
bout de son nez enfin ils commencent à
pointer le bout de son nez
oui et non il est disponible en magasin
depuis le 9 février uniquement aux yeux
et ça en angleterre et en australie
en ce qui nous concerne pour la france
et pour l'allemagne il va falloir encore
attendre un petit peu et il va arriver
au printemps assurez-vous c'est une
question de jours de l'eau jour
effectivement mais lyon peut être va
enfin pouvoir arriver chez nous si on
souhaite l'acheter d'ailleurs je vous
invite à vous abonner parce que c'est
vrai qu'on va beaucoup en parler ce
mmorpg est hyper intéressant pas
uniquement parce que on pense que c'est
une enceinte connectés en réalité en
poste c'est bien plus que ça l'est au
centre d'une stratégie de conquête
d'apple et c'est ce que je vais vous
expliquer dans cette vidéo on va essayer
de comprendre ce qu'est le mode ce à
quoi il va nous servir est en réalité qu
est ce qui se joue derrière parce que ne
vous laissez pas tromper le mode n'est
pas une enceinte collectés alors oui
dans l'absolu c'est une enceinte
connectés ça vous sert à écouter de la
musique
ça va vous servir effectivement à faire
pas mal de choses chez vous mais c'est
pas seulement une enceinte collectés
stratégiquement il y a un intérêt qui
est beaucoup plus grand beaucoup plus
fort pour apple
et c'est justement ce qu'on va regarder
maintenant quand on parle du mode il
faut pas se tromper le mode n'est pas
seulement une enceinte connecter le mode
c'est la nouvelle stratégie gagnante
d'apple pour les années à venir
c'est la nouvelle pièce maîtresse
d'apple qui va prendre plus en plus de
place dans nos foyers pour moi sommes
pod ses produits intermédiaires entre
l'ipod et le robot d'apple parce que oui
on va y aller dans les années à venir on
va aller sur les robots aujourd'hui
c'est clair il est encore un peu tôt
pour vraiment se projeter là dessus mais
très clairement c'est là dessus qu'on se
dessine car oui la robotique c'est
quelque chose qu'ils développent
énormément et d'ici 15 à 20 ans on aura
un robot dans nos foyers au mode est en
quelque sorte le prémice de ses futurs
robots sans côté affectif
je m'explique à quoi serviront les
robots dans le futur à vous simplifier
la vie à gagner du temps et à faire
toutes les tâches ingrates à votre place
comme on pourra interagir plus
profondément avec eux parce qu'il va y
avoir un développement de l'intelligence
artificielle on aura de l'empathie pour
eux et les robots font partie de notre
famille
alors certes on n'en est pas encore là
ça fait un peu de science fiction il
dire comme ça mais pourtant c'est bien
vrai
et c'est comme ça que ça va se passer
aujourd'hui vous trop peut-être ça
déconne ans mais croyez-moi ça arrivera
chez vous ou chez vos enfants d'ailleurs
sur mes coups temps vous vous dites ou à
snake déconne et dit n'importe quoi
dites vous bien que vous dit que la même
chose que vos parents ou vos grands
parents à l'aube des années 80 70
lorsque les premiers ordinateurs sont
arrivés on voyait pas forcément leur
utilité on disait qu'on n'allait pas en
avoir besoin en avoir un chez soi pour
quoi faire
au final lorsqu'ils vont regarder
l'évolution trente ans après vous avez
tous des smartphones dans votre poche
donc croyez moi ils robots vont arriver
chez vous vous y croyez ou non que vous
vouliez ou non les robots vont arriver
chez vous donc en quoi est ce que
l'homme paul est la pierre angulaire
stratégique pour apple qui vous
permettra passé de l'ipod à la robotique
lorsque vous allez sur le site d'apple y
écrit au mode et la nouvelle enceinte
sans fil innovantes d'apple
je vous laisse donc croire que c'est une
enceinte connectés qui va jouer
uniquement la musique d'apple musique ou
alors les morceaux qui sont présents
dans nos époques dans vos ipad ou dans
votre iphone mais en réalité c'est bien
plus que ça apple développe de plus en
plus à solutions pour la maison
connectée home kit grâce à siri
notamment vous pouvez piloter votre
maison jouaient de la musique
allumez la télé ouvrir fermer les stores
allumer et éteindre la lumière envoyer
un message et bien plus encore alors
vous me direz oui mais tout ça c'est que
déjà le faire avec mon iphone
oui sauf que là où l'iphone est un objet
personnel l'homme pod est l'objet du
foyer et c'est là que se fait la
différence ça peut paraître être une
toute petite nuance mais elle a vraiment
son importance en peau devient
l'interface de référence chez vous pour
jouer de la musique et surtout pour
gérer votre foyer
la stratégie d'apple est très clair avec
l'iphone ils sont déjà rentrés dans
votre intimité avec un code
ils vont rentrer en plus dans l'ensemble
de votre foyer au moins vous êtes
shannon paul uniquement pour vous à moi
que vous habitiez chez vos parents que
vous mettiez l'opcode dans votre chambre
et que personne n'en profite mais dites
vous bien qu'un jour vous allez avoir
votre chez vous votre appart et l'homme
pod trouvera sa place de choix au milieu
un jour vous aurez une famille va très
probablement en tout cas un jour vous
aurez une famille un foyer et votre ipod
ou son évolution trouvera sa place de
choix aux 5 29 ans et comme apple est
une entreprise fermée tous les produits
sont optimisées pour fonctionner
ensemble donc vous nouerez absolument
entre guillemets aucune porte de sortie
vous serez apple alors rassurez-vous
jeudi apple mais c'est vrai pour les
autres samsung par exemple a aussi une
solution pour la maison connectée
il vous connecte leur plaque de cuisson
avec leurs fonds
avec leur frigo avec un écosystème
complet avec votre tablette avec votre
smartphone on voit très bien
qu'aujourd'hui la maison est fait pour
fonctionner ensemble autour d'un seul et
même device avec au coeur une
intelligence artificielle chez apple
elle s'appelle syrie chez samsung
elle s'appelle bixby et ça ça va se
développer de plus en plus aujourd'hui
ce qui se joue c'est une bière terrain
objets connectés par objets connectés
pour rentrer chez vous et dès lors
qu'une marque est présente chez vous
avec un écosystème complet lorsque tout
sera prêt les robots arriveront chez
vous alors comme ça on pourra croire je
trouve ça pas cool mais dans l'absolu je
trouve ça plutôt intéressant je vous dis
ça parce qu'il faut pas être naïf au
mode c'est pas simplement la nouvelle
enceinte connectés d'apple mon pote
c'est bien plus que ça c'est une vraie
stratégie c'est une vraie vision de
l'avenir pour apple il ya d'abord eu les
mac les ipod les iphone
ensuite les ipad les watch et la lhomme
pod l'homme pote ki vien vraiment
destiné cette nouvelle stratégie de
conquête par apple d'ailleurs on le voit
très bien si vous regardez les chiffres
de 2010 est au dernier trimestre 2010
est apple a battu ses records au niveau
de son chiffre d'affaires mais pourtant
les ventes d iphone sont pas
extraordinaires ça veut donc dire
qu'apple gagne du terrain sur d'autres
produits et d'autres services parce que
quand on pense apple on pense iphone on
pense mac on pense ipad mais faut pas
oublier qu'apple chose derrière il ya de
la télé il ya des lecteurs mp3 il ya un
service de musique en ligne
effectivement des smartphones il ya des
tablettes il ya des casques sans fil
il ya des casques avec fils il ya tout
un ensemble de produits qui se
développent et en posant au centre de sa
un obligé chez vous apple va continuer à
gagner du terrain et à vous fidéliser
d'ailleurs si l'homme pas de vous
intéresse je vous invite à aller voir ma
précédente vidéo je vous présente plus
en détails de ce que j'ai pu en voir de
ce que j'ai pu en lire de ce que j'ai pu
écouter c'est un produit qui a l'air
d'être plutôt pas mal qui est vraiment
optimisé et qui pour l'instant a plutôt
un bon accueil
restez connectés pas ce que je vais vous
en parle dans les temps à venir c'est
quelque chose de super intéressant
d'ailleurs je vous invite à me donner
votre avis qu'est ce que vous pensez de
tout ce que je viens de vous dire est ce
que vous trouvez ça complètement
déconnant est ce que ça vous paraît
farfelue ahurissant est ce que vous êtes
plutôt d'accord est ce que vous pensez
effectivement que l'homme pod est au
coeur de la stratégie d'apple pourront
vous fidélisez et pour rentrer davantage
dans votre maison dans votre foyer merci
beaucoup d'abord regarder cette vidéo je
vous invite
vous abonner à rester connectés parce
qu'on a parlé toujours plus toujours
mieux de nouveaux produits
j'ai plein de choses à vous montrer
plein de choses à partager avec vous je
vous invite comme d'habitude a blessé
des jolies pouces
on reste connectés je vous dis à très
bientôt portez vous bien je vous
embrasse
soyez sages
[Musique]